dix mois
sophie duez duo julie devrais-je tulle
et choisit plutôt gironde des
partenaires non je sais pas j'ai tourné
aussi avec balasko lavanant je ne dis
pas qu'elles soient pas gironde mais tu
as dit quand le réalisateur aime
l'actrice c'est mieux stylo godard
karina par exemple il ya quelque chose
en plus tu asie alors avec godrèche et
quelque chose en plus les quelque chose
en moins mais avec godrèche qui a le
talent en plus de tous et donc
qu'est-ce que de quoi un metteur en
scène pour être il rêvait si ce n'est
d'avoir en face de lui une comédienne
qui a un talent extraordinaire et qui
est extraordinairement le personnage tu
refuses pas l'épithète de pervers que tu
préfères un malsain peut même dire que
tu l'as eu le second père beurre malsain
est totalement négative disant que
malsain c'est un pervers raté mais c'est
bien la perversion c'est comme le sait
comme le piment dans la cuisine
asiatique s'est dit moi me coûte est
toujours aussi obsédé par la mort
bien sûr bien sûr tu crois pas que si tu
croyait en dieu c'était vrai à vivre
certainement ça j'en suis absolument
certain mais on ne décide pas de croire